hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Wade and Bob say hi
Guys hi Guys hi same joke is weighed and
wah-ha-ha-ha weird evolving together
grown up you're losers we are on the
moon and as you can see it's a big
woman's panic everybody there's aliens
here ah that I found a long time never
seen this book to be in front of ya we
are suddenly in this place we found
aliens we own noon I'll I I was trying
to give you guys credit
I found aliens on the moon and I hate
you then I brought them over and guess
what we have zombie MA we have zombie
back so weird of we kind of like a
terminator version yeah he's some sort
of Borg far dragon blood cry I don't
know back from the dead
yeah back from that's good about John
Connor or something though and then we
poured him a nice joke there wait not
funny but clever anyway so we're gonna
get sharp we're gonna what we're gonna
do is we're gonna explore all the Moon
has to offer and for some reason my
oxygen tank was going down oh by the way
we have oxygen tanks and gears and all
sorts of cool stuff like that my oxygen
tanks were low and then Olson they like
shot back up so I don't know I don't
know why things are growing here or how
but they is way just in tanks
automatically refill if you're like buy
stuff that's what I'm wondering I don't
think that's how it works but hey
whatever anyway I'm still drinking the
same drink I was drunken before just
like a liter mug here [ __ ] thank you
you're drunk I was trucking before
drunkenly I trouble the nastiest green
I've ever seen in my life
it's getting worse as it goes down it's
the baby [ __ ] yeah
lovely lovely Mountain Dew in Disaronno
don't mix it it's actually not that bad
it doesn't taste bad your tree looks
awful you look awful what's wrong with
my tree it's better
that's wrong someone opened the door you
open the door
open zombies talking with the aliens
Bobby knows about this hobby look wha
wha wait do you still have that our whoa
read chat what to evolve creeper green
chat what
yeah what's chattering it just said it
said see that it's a never mind whatever
I needed or a chat shut up shut up you
all
you guys aren't good enough to see what
I was seeing you suck you suck more ah
okay door I put on aura yeah zombies is
that really the door we're gonna go with
for our mood base yeah this is our moon
base door shut up I'm more concerned
about what's going on over here with the
creepers with the gasp oxygen mask and
tank on them aren't you too concerned at
all about yeah we have a cyborg guarding
it so I'm pretty confident okay anyway
so we got our little house here but I'm
guessing the problem is it has no oxygen
to begin with or I oh no I got this yeah
there's no oxygen in here except kids
are doing the no oxygen no you took my
oxygen tank that I was leaking into here
oh okay I don't think it works like that
I uh I have an idea I'm gonna steal from
the aliens yeah yeah do that I'm gonna
start a war with them wait oxygen pipe
oxygen compressor oxygen collector I'm
gonna put an oxygen collector near their
trees and then pump it into our dome hey
if you hit the aliens with a sword they
just stare at you don't hit the aliens
we're trying to be peaceful oh we are
yes we're gonna be I'm sorry friend
that's how we say hello in America well
then hello and he stabs you in the face
that never works it always works okay I
what are you seeing scary movie 3 not
enough power look at
collect look it's collecting oxygen
how'd you get oxygen it's collecting
oxygen so these trees are dying now uh
what witcha trees find it some more
trees oh yeah hang on a minute I'm gonna
this is gonna work I'm gonna box it June
us I'm gonna pump I'm gonna steal their
oxygen pump it our house it's gonna work
that one Bob leaves the door open I
don't we how do we connect it I don't
know there's like a bunch of oxygen if
there's an oxygen compressor an oxygen
bubble distributor which i think is what
I need to put here OOP nope that's the
wrong side I need a wrench to turn that
sumbitch and I'm gonna look at all this
out of course I'm staying here doing
nothing
I'm totally legitimately doing this here
we go look look look so is the oxygen in
here now not enough oxygen because this
isn't powered but Han come up here look
by the trees you see this oxygen thingy
it's shocking it's shocking oxygen n but
it doesn't that much power not not
enough to be happening over here so we
need to give it power it doesn't have
enough power they need I don't think
this is correct actually but I'm going
with then over here are you working I'm
going to keep drinking and try to make
this work oh I don't ah what are we ah
what is going on ah didn't we have an
objective yes survive on the moon I feel
like we're doing that pretty well
sealable oxygen pipe would why is there
a warp door who put a warp door on it
which one of you which one of you silly
Billy's I don't never put my last warp
door I'm going in wait a bit hey I
better replace it all with sealable
oxygen tanks that's mine my scre moved
wrongly the server just ours about pops
door oh my god can I get in our landers
and get out of here I'm leaving
No
oh yes I just wrote the door to the
dimension you went to Bob I'm not sure
you can come back and let say losses
work on the moon I don't think this is
correct what are you making this is
awful it looks it said sealable oxygen
pipe I thought holy crap these launchers
are these Landers that we um that we
landed on the moon with uh-huh if you
right-click on them their chests and
they're full of fuel canister launch pad
and spaceship ha ha
really yes Wow about a year [ __ ] hey
good this aliens are watching us Billy
need all right all fuel cell that's fuel
but narced hard look outside the door
here Lily is just watching us look
they're just who is this there's a
person running around out here I think
there's a zombie mold it might be either
that or house wigs run your dress in the
middle of nowhere dude nothing
the IP address to this server was like
cheeseburger if you guys want to join
yeah join in come on down this oxygen
collector is not working
I need a what's the battery what is the
battery a battery it's not a matter II
what is it called Oh yawning I think I
shot a rink [ __ ] sell fuel canister I
got it no maybe I don't know put this in
there yeah yeah no that didn't work nah
here let me see this is in joules we
need watts how did we work this don't
work what is I've done this before what
is the thingy it's an energy cellar
energy how did an alien get inside of
our house I hope you let it in I didn't
the doors closed but there's one just in
there you suck ok um help me think of
this I'm building an escape pod hang on
I don't care about an escape pod look
up on the internet what the hell powers
it portably what's it called
now your G hey guys look what I don't
clear a reactor right next to it screw
you guys where's my solar I like mark
mark we have an issue with the house why
look wait I don't have you that you're
bringing the alien I read it all before
a guide um and all the house honey
are in here why do you're launching a
freaking rocket it's not launching and
sitting it's still there by ha well here
I'll just launch it and I'll fly around
can you like turn it back so that you
crash into the planet could you do that
I knew yeah did you put the launch pad
on top of the house I don't seem like a
good idea
Ivan why would that not be an acceptable
idea hi me hi me I'm waving I waved to
myself I need to put some whoa where is
he where you going boss a circle I'll be
back okay oh man oh God okay re enough
of that no none of that know that none
of that we need to figure out how to
survive right
Wade yes cuz Baba come here come here
Wade help me figure this out look up on
the Internet's internets what powers in
tech it what does it call it's not a
battery it's not an energy cell it's up
mmm-hmm power converter generator
generator
build a generator that's what I'm gonna
build
Jen her a tour
are you guys you still see me biofuel
generator this is crass oh I just saw
you
ha ha ha I fly in a big circle
uh you won't co-op hi mom I see how your
screw it I tried to work I tried to do
what we were supposed to do I tried you
all you all saw do you all suck I I'm
sick of it I'm sick and tired ha hey one
of the rocket exploded it's gonna
explode I am sick and tired of dealing
with your goal I am coming to get you
Bob I'm going to I'm going to find you
and come and get you
mark I'm right here dad is out of fuel
this is the non fuel rocket okay I got
some fuel here come here
no screw you I got this gather I'm in
this I'm coming to get you Bob
I'm coming to get you looking at this
from my third-person perspective
come here oh my god now what happened
wait what is aam be building hey hold on
stop dude stop killing me what's up
building hold on hold on
well then what's he building was he
building Oh Oh did he learn makeshift
alien oh he actually knows what he's
doing with Leela how does her walking
the other hand do not ha ha ha
oh quit beating the alien get your
spaceship Wade just race ships down gear
spaceship alwey jeez I'm gonna give him
a spaceship your ticket spaceship Wade
oh you already have one yes ah Persian
it looks better stupid ah now go into
2nd person mode rah-rah oh this is not
with the people who made tag it had in
mind
I miss me no other Creators any game had
us in mind for the day
ha ha ha ha ha wait oh don't be too shy
Ellen tired I almost choked the mouse
bit okay I'm dead up desk oh good I'm
done I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm done
I'm done
whoo
all right wait Bob you go there I'm
gonna launch over here Wade you launch
your own ship and we're all gonna fly
around in circles okay okay okay
don't lie low drokken feel you got a
build a pre fueled rocket I'll toss them
down here have that one someone have the
other one I'm tossing them there get him
better get him they're gonna loves oh I
think they exploded I'm not sure ah I'm
waiting at you right now
hi I see that hi Bob we both in it no no
are we looking they're here bar doing it
I'm in it where are you yeah I mean it
yeah I wait okay wait
Bob you're right here on my screen and
mark you're underground for you I'm not
hiding the damn ship I pilot in the show
I'm piling to the ship I'm piloting the
ship
I show I'm piloting the ship we're going
straight down that's what we're doing
kara yeah uh-huh you're trying to point
it up aren't you no I'm trying to put it
back down what are you doing I'm trying
to point it down you fired then yes I
will fly it thank you now can I say the
ground
well are we leaving I'm trying to go
down why are we leaving the planet moon
leaving the planet I'm trying to go back
down crew it I'm out of here
how do I get out of this ship wait I
can't exit I can't act it either said
Bobbie ruin the ship without me yeah
they're so dumb yeah yeah yeah I don't
deny that ad wait wait I'm almost dead
you kick don't kill it no it's not to
mind what the hell zombie was building
see let's just see it's like living
peacefully we're disturbing
zombies secret lab a mmm zombies labs
whoo looks fancy Oh interesting yes
what's going on in here it's a cyborg
need with a lab oh he's up to no good
he's up to no good
hi Tommy hi what are you building
Oh whoa gun he shot a gun he's got a gun
he's gone crazy
oh hi mates
oh no I'm lost attack I'm taking all
your [ __ ] wait
oxygen is blown up hey JP Lee okay I got
ya I got ya uh-huh
you're over here now no I'll give ya
here oh yeah
look Jen here Oh stand right there are
tensed are you dead yet
oh that oh crap I slit at the chin thing
off to put a power gauntlet on I didn't
war tanks guys shut up Wade you complain
so damn much my eyes are dynamite
I guess we're not supposed to mess with
zombie right now he's busy in his
private lab Bob you took all my stuff oh
is the best I love you for work ah worst
where's the ha I have a parachute now I
want to use it uh y-you don't need a
parachute on the mound you can't even
die or well you can die but not from
falling right Wade you have no proof
that I have your stuff you're wearing my
diamond armor hahahaha that's Aaron
square I had the back engrave you know
what I just realized these aliens look
like Squidward ha ha ha the giant knows
the big tall head Hey look the and
they're blue where's Squidward bird he's
Squidward we're all Squidward why is
there a walking box oh my god he's
building robots he's building a robot
army he's what he's building a robot
army Oh No
you think we have any Launchpad left I'm
out of here I got a large bag all my
stuff here Bob do it you go home Bob go
home it's not worth it staying here you
look at it look at all then go no fuel
no fuel you didn't get a fueled rocket
well that sucks yeah I have a partially
filled fuel canister how do I use it I
don't know don't ask me oh man thanks
perfect when it comes to fly
learn rocket ships so zombies creating
his army of robots on the moon that are
steadily mining resources for my stuff
got blown all over the place I'm still
fighting pieces
yeah what did he hit you with death
attack what on attack dot what is Jeff
attack weapon apparently something
that's lethal I want to find out and
shoot you in the face with it ah I don't
see it enough in the menu probably of
you have to make oh bad
okay so did we have an objective all we
were supposed to do letter substitution
this whole time
oh alright rules we're supposed to not
say the letter S which reflects it with
the letter K that's where we're go yes
good [ __ ] or yek yek we're gonna replace
the letter a coup or k with k so from
now on we can't K hey got it
wait would it be ech no it'd be okay cuz
cuz you replace K is like uh because
with you easy be Kok be Kok hit be kaga
it could what I can little cook cut up
Wade you to tupid AK hole I hate your Co
dog yo [ __ ] dick is you cut it how much
the dumbest idea we've ever had dick
bombing it can't even talking Bob is
Kumari kid ink you can't take it back
bob is with now with ik with drawing
from this competition Vic covetous every
time you
miss Mick pronunciate hahahaha you can't
Kate brenneke a can oh yeah oh yeah q
can you I know however you have a rook
anymore
you got to drink when you don't play K
but kick kack aw come on cook is my
favorite type of band
I love [ __ ] ah ha ha you like big becau
like no bird could call cook ah okay
this dick was supposed to be fun but
Wade is a ketubah dak hole a cut open
and cooks the fun out of everything
yeah you can't cake Bob you cannot visit
WIC withdraw from the competition you
mocked K come thing I'm trying to get
this robot to kill you you said you did
not oh okay when you were saying dang
okay I'm going to drink now Vic was a
ketubah die dia deke come yeah your code
um oh I'm going why do we have any of
you were ha ha ha my fan oh I'm leaving
thick flake you spelt you Capel face
every day okay why letter okay you're
cold oh wait Berg ha ha ha ha I'm a coke
lad happy
good oh I'm in a hole
well climb out of that hole
looka me why is it Sambi patil ik
cahooting us OCH cahooting uck y zombie
Emmett zombie wait yeah that's that
ticket correct he's eeky eeky kuru do
daily occur no Billy alien cam Yule he
walked my best friend okay hahaha
you [ __ ] it did yeah we commend Chucky
how much time Vic
Coleco yeah together Nick we count not
work first we we to pooned ah all night
long
what it Cooper and you know Couponing
Big Al Capone come Al Capone like Canoga
bunnies bunny you know kupuna ng like
Kanaga bunny that really clear it up for
me I'm Co glad oh my god honey you come
now a bunny
you could Yuki now what I'm King you can
he well you can e now what I hate it
thick are we gonna keep doing it
look I don't know could why Diane cook
this was a stupid idea cooker it look
all right got ya
that's over we're done we're done all
right I can talk again
come key what Bob luck trying to program
Bob that's not fair you can't just
exclude yourself from the competition by
not talking
I didn't lose uh right click this mail a
turtle ha ha ha why Bob why ha ha ha
ja kita for that we're gonna keep
talking in Coutu paid language yeah you
Marcus you talk or Erica you saw the
punishment I will only um I am trapped
in the hole we all have a different
letter substitution oh I will substitute
all these with s's you kind of a [ __ ]
ah I hate your gut - then what is mine
you must replace Elvis be who replace F
with me ha ha and I will stick with K
and s what the buck are you trying to
get me nicely in a way with Z yes you
could have that ha ha ha
be careful if that work it means you are
going to try the river ha ha ha I can't
even think of a word with a Z in it that
I want to say buzz why would I want to
say that zip why would I want to say
that I guess a balls with a Z but I just
saved some tasty to takes in a ziploc
bag wick with a 1 costs and meccanica
Pisces it will be delicious
shook click my big haha [ __ ] my pinochle
letter replace ha ha ha ha ha I just
kind of gave myself a list get on your
knee and [ __ ] why all right we're done
I'm done we're out of time
oh my god you're the worst we've got
nothing besides build this monstrosity
of a house that has nothing but dirt and
water in it three episodes we've gone to
the moon and built a glass house ha ha
ha this is like an hour and a half of
nothing why do you guys watch this ok
thank you ha ha ha ha that's attack what
are dying
ha ha ha why do I live lingering why are
you watching us ugh so see you
Wade at Lord minion 777 Bob on Twitter
at my cooker meeee like occur Myka curb
my skirm and me you're already probably
gonna unsubscribe to me wait wait wait
does that make me Lord minion Kevin
Kevin Kevin s Lord crash tag Lord minion
Kevin Kevin Kevin subscribe to Lord
minion Kevin Kevin Kevin I'm thinking
zero Club crabbers now come cry Burke
come cry Burke ok so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching um we're
probably done with TECA for now we've
explored everything there is to explore
so thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotation values
that we've done and as always sprites
creepers we will see
video
what is
bud
something might pop up when it turns
around
yeah well what